Now our probability problems
will get a little bit
more interesting.
So let's say I have a
bag full of coins.
So this is my bag of coins,
maybe it's a bowl of coins.
From a bunch of coins in there.
I didn't need to draw
it, but I did anyway.
And let's say that I know that
9 of these coins are normal.
So what do I mean my normal?
Just, you know, let's say
they're quarters and they have
a heads and a tails, and that
there's a 50% chance of getting
a heads or 50% chance of
a tails if you flip
any of those coins.
And then, 1 of the coins
is a two-sided head coin.
So essentially, no matter
what you flip it, it's
going to be a heads.
So I have this bag, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to
blindfold myself, stick my
hand in the bag, and
pick a coin out.
And then I'm going to flip
that coin, I'm going
to flip it five times.
And my question to you is,
what is the probability that
I get all 5 to be heads?
So whenever you see something
unfamiliar it'll always work--
maybe we'll do a tree or we'll
do a hybrid of a probability
tree or something else.
But you say, well, at the very
beginning of this experiment
something happens.
I'm going to pick a
coin out of this bag.
And so you could say that
there's a-- well, how
many coins are there?
There's 10 coins and I have an
equal probability of picking
any one of the coins.
Let's say I can't feel
whether it's heads or tails.
I'm doing it with gloves
on, so I can't feel out
the two-sided coin.
Take my word for it, there's
an equal probability to take
any 1 of these 10 coins.
There's 9 normal, 1 weird
with 2 heads on it.
So what's the probability
that I get a normal coin?
Well, there are 9 normal
coins out of the 10 equally
likely coins I could get.
So the probability of a
normal is 9 out of 10.
So there's a 9 out of 10 chance
that this is a normal coin
Let's just call that normal.
And then, what's the
probability that I get
a-- let's call it a
2s-- two-sided coin.
I'll call it 2s.
Well, that's just 1 out of 10.
I'm either going to
get this or that.
I'm not going to take nothing
out of the bag I assume.
OK, so this is a 1/10 chance
that I get a two-sided coin.
And then whichever coin
I get I'm going to flip
it five times in a row.
And I'm not going to do
the tree here because
to drew a tree I'd have
32 nodes on each side.
But given this, given
the normal, what is
now the probability of
getting 5 in a row?
The way I'm going to write that
is the probability of 5 heads--
or I could have written 5
out of 5 heads, whatever.
And then this upper line, this
means given-- given that
I have a normal coin.
So if I can assume that I had a
normal coin, what are the
probabilities that my next 5--
so I'll say this is
5 out of 5 heads.
Well, we figure that out.
Each time there's a 1/2
probability and I'm going
to do it 5 in a row.
So it's 1/2 to the fifth,
which equals 1/32.
So the probability that I get
5 out of 5 heads given a
normal coin is 1 out of 32.
Fair enough.
Well, what's the probability
of 5 out of 5 heads,
given the two-sided coin?
And now just is this random
notation I'm coming
with the two-sided.
But this upwards and downwards
line, this vertical
line, that means given.
I mean I could flip this coin
a million times and all of
them are going to be heads.
So the probability
here is 1 out of 1.
I'm definitely going
to get a heads here.
So all I asked initially is,
what is the probability that
I get 5 out of 5 heads?
Well, this is going to be equal
to-- and I'll switch colors
arbitrarily here just to
keep things interesting.
This is going to be equal to
the probability that you get 5
out of 5 heads given-- let's
call that a normal coin-- given
a normal coin times the
probability that you had a
normal coin times
the probability of
let's say normal.
Plus-- and I'm running a little
out of space-- the probability
that you get 5 out of 5 heads
given the two-sided coin times
the probability that you had
the two-sided sided coin.
Hopefully that makes sense and
you kind of think of it in this
way, what is the probability
of getting to this outcome?
It is the probability that you
picked a normal coin and then,
given the normal coin,
there's a 1 in 32 chance
that you got there.
So it'd be 1 out of 32
times the chance you've
got the normal coin.
So 9 out of 10.
And what's the probability
of getting here?
What's the probability you had
to-- and, in general, in a
tree, you just have to multiply
all of the nodes to get to that
point to figure out what's the
probability of getting there.
And I think if you watched
the first few videos it make
sense why that happens.
So what's the
probability of this?
Well, there's a 1/10 chance
that you picked the
two-sided coin.
And then of course, you're
guaranteed to get all heads.
This is 1 times 1/10.
And all I did here and
here is the same thing
that I wrote up here.
Let me switch colors.
So what is this, the
probability of 5 out of 5 heads
given a normal coin times the
probability of a normal coin?
Well, that's just this.
This is the probability of 5
out of 5 heads given the normal
coin times the probability
of a normal coin.
And this is equal to what?
9/320.
And then this, the probability
of 5 out of 5 heads given the
two-sided coin times the
probability of the
two-sided coin.
Well, this is the probability
of 5 out of 5 heads given
the two-sided coin, you're
guaranteed to get 5 out of 5.
And the probability of
getting a two-sided
coin is 1 out of 10.
This is this.
So this is equal to 1/10.
So my probability of just
putting my hand in the bag,
taking out a random coin and
then flipping it five times and
getting all 5 heads, is going
to be equal to this plus this.
So it's 9/320.
plus 1/10.
But let's make
that so it's 320.
That's 32/320.
So 9 plus 32 is 41/320.
So that's interesting.
But now let me ask you even a
more interesting question.
This is why I think what we've
learned so far is useful.
Let's say that I do
get 5 out of 5 heads.
So I know that I got
5 out of 5 heads.
So let me clear this up a
little bit just because I think
it's getting over-- So let's
say that I do get
5 out of 5 heads.
What is the probability that
I picked the two-sided coin?
So what we're asking is, what
is the probability that I
picked the two-sided coin,
given that I got 5
out of 5 heads?
And I hope you understand
what I mean here.
Before we said, oh, for
example, I hope you see the
difference between this and
what is the probability of
getting 5 out of 5 heads,
given the two-sided coin.
If I know I have a two-sided
coin, I know that the
probability is equal to 1.
I know that I'm guaranteed
to get 5 heads.
But this is a little
bit more interesting.
If I flip a coin five times in
a row and I get a bunch of
heads, I'll say, well, I either
got maybe really lucky with a
normal coin or I picked
the two-sided coin.
And I don't know which
one happened, so
there's a probability.
And of course, the more times
you get a heads, just
intuitively, if I got 100 heads
in a row I'll say, well, I
probably picked the two-sided
coin without actually just
looking at the coin.
We're assuming that
that's not acceptable.
And if I got a million heads in
a row we'd be really, really
sure that we picked the
two-sided coin, but we're
not completely sure.
There's some probability that I
picked the fair coin and it
just happened to get heads
a million times in a row.
So how do we think about this?
Well, I'll do it analytically
and I'll draw it out, and
hopefully, both of them
will make sense to you.
And I'll probably have to
do it in the next video.
I'll see you soon.